[Musica]
mi chiamo
dopo ero in sé per 31 anni zoologia
all'università del salento
la zoologia è una materia che spesso non
viene ritenuta molto seria se dico che
sono uno zoologo pensano che dia da
mangiare leggi alle girasse in qualche
zo
però
il creatore da un solo incarico ad adamo
nella genesi dare il nome gli animali
non ce ne sono altri dare il nome agli
animali vuol dire studiare la
biodiversità
noi abbiamo cominciato la nostra
avventura sul pianeta come cacciatori
raccoglitori e dovevamo conoscere gli
animali e le piante gli animali di
solito li conoscevano i maschi perché
andavano a caccia le femmine e piccoli
conoscevano la botanica
questa tendenza
a conoscere la biodiversità è ancora
presente nei giovani esemplari della
nostra specie edward wilson la chiama
biophilia se voi prendete un bambino e
una bambina li portate su una spiaggia
in un bosco
sono interessati a quello che hanno
attorno fanno domande se glielo spiega
te se lo ricordano non lo devono
studiare
ora portateli a scuola
quanta natura c'è la scuola
i bambini tornano a casa non conoscono i
nomi degli alberi che incontrano mentre
tornano a casa e non li sanno neanche i
loro docenti non sanno se sono alberi
autoctoni cioè del posto dove vivono se
vengono magari e dall'australia come gli
eucalipti
c'è una grande ignoranza di cose di
natura noi oggi ci siamo accorti che non
è stato un bene e stiamo programmando la
transizione ecologica se si transita la
transizione ecologica significa che
siamo in un posto dove l'ecologia non
conta nulla e dobbiamo transitare in un
posto dove l'ecologia conta
l'ecologia vuol dire biodiversità
ecosistemi
quanto c'è di tutto questo
nell'istruzione
formale che viene impartita ai giovani
non c'è praticamente nulla
nelle mie prime lezioni all'università a
un certo punto mi sono accorto che
dovevo far capire questo ai miei
studenti e ho fatto cominciava le mie
lezioni scrivendo sulla lavagna pim pim
popò
che differenza c'è tra la pipì e la popò
me n'ero accorto perché non capivano la
differenza tra l'escrezione
l'eliminazione e quindi dicevo chi è che
mi sa spiegare avete visto
in televisione
miss italia che beve l'acqua poi fa
tanta plin plin e quindi e diventa
sempre più bella
bevete un litro d'acqua poi fatela pp
che strada ha fatto l'acqua chi lo sa
chi è che è in grado di spiegarlo
forza chi è in grado di spiegare chi è
che pensa di essere in grado di
spiegarlo non vi umili e rho poi
chiedendovi di spiegarmelo
però chi è che pensa di saperlo
nessuno no una volta una ragazza b dice
lo so io dico va bene dai dimmelo
e questa mi dice abbiamo due apparati
digerenti 1 per i solidi e uno per i
liquidi quando mangiamo va nel sistema
dei soli 10 alla pop o quando beviamo va
in quello dei liquidi esce la pipì se ci
va qualcosa per traverso e perché la
cosa ha preso la strada sbagliata
e tutti ridevano ridevano però non
sapevano la risposta come voi state
ammettendo di non saperla questa ragazza
ovviamente era la più in gamba di tutte
perché
aveva fatto quello che fa la scienza di
solito la scienza ha due compiti
uno è quello di identificare
l'ignoranza e quindi sapere che non stai
qualcosa e l'altro è quello di cercare
di ridurla
di solito gli scienziati che fanno
elaborano ipotesi e quindi questa aveva
elaborato l'ipotesi dei due apparati
digerenti perché in effetti c'era un
buco solo poi ce ne due escono fuori due
cose diverse quindi pensava due tubi che
portavano lì è un po come il sole che
gira attorno alla terra per tanto tempo
abbiamo pensato questo era la cosa più
ovvia
ovviamente poi uno fa esperimenti fa
prove si accorge che l'ipotesi non
funziona e passa ad altre ipotesi che
poi cercherà di verificare funziona così
la scienza se però non sai che non lo
sai non riuscirei mai a ridurre la tua
ignoranza
e noi siamo ignoranti di natura in modo
pressoché totale e quindi è difficile
pensare di fare la transizione ecologica
senza sapere nulla di come funzionano
gli ecosistemi e la biodiversità che
vorremmo salvaguardare in 13 anni 5 anni
di lì elementari 3 di media e 5 di liceo
non hanno imparato come funziona il loro
corpo
però sanno e fu siccome immobile dato il
mortal sospiro stette la spoglia
immemore orba di tanto così percorsa
toni dalla terra annunzio st e poi sanno
dimostrare teoremi e così via io una
volta ho avuto uno studente che pensava
che il 5 maggio fosse una un omaggio a
garibaldi perché era partito il 5 maggio
dallo scoglio di quarto e quindi non
capiva nemmeno bene che cosa stava
imparando però lo imparava e io quando
sento dire che studiare a memoria le
poesie e formativo dico no mi dispiace
no come non lo è imparare le
dimostrazioni dei teoremi
la scuola è molto astratta ci sono
concetti astratti quando i bambini
arrivano a scuola vorrebbero certe cose
quelle che incontrano nel bosco sulla
spiaggia e gli vengono date altre cose
hanno voglia di imparare
non con sacrificio perché non deve
essere un sacrificio andare a scuola e
invece viene presentato come ti devi
sacrificare perché devi soffrire per
andare avanti
e questo secondo me è
probabilmente la carenza numero uno
della nostra scuola
l'assenza di concretezza e
l'impossibilità di
riconoscerle l'ignoranza ti danno cose
che devi imparare e tu le impari
come un bue una volta poi dico ma
scusate
che differenza c'è tra un buon toro
ha un buon toro
è una mi dice il bue il maschio della
mucca e il toro è il maschio della bacca
cioè gente che è arrivata all'università
è dicono
e che differenziazione tra la vacca la
mucca ebbene la mucca la femmina del
toro e la vacca è la femmina del boom
dico non è così vi assicuro che era come
la pipì non lo sapeva nessuno
e quando ho detto che un bue un toro
castrato due son date di gomito e hanno
parlato di lorena bobbit lorena bobbit
aveva evirato il marito non lo aveva
castrato e quindi ho dovuto fare disegni
sulla lavagna per far vedere la
differenza tra le due cose i livelli
sono questi e siamo all'università
quindi c'è tutta una serie di cose che
si imparano nei percorsi scolastici che
dovrebbe essere preceduta da un'altra
serie di cose
adesso faccio una supercazzola
ernst e che l'ha detto l'onta genesi e
ricapitola la filogenesi è una cosa che
qualcuno forse ha perfino imparato loro
genesi significa lo sviluppo di un
organismo da l'uovo fecondato che è una
cellula fino all organismo adulto
l'ontogenesi sono tutti gli stati
dell'embriologia attraverso i quali
passiamo anche noi
per passare da una singola cellula a un
organismo completo la filogenesi e la
storia evolutiva dell'ohr della specie a
cui appartiene quell'organismo per cui è
che il vedeva nello sviluppo embrionale
di una persona per esempio uno stadio
unicellulare ovviamente poi c'era uno
stadio vedeva lo stadio di pesce poi di
anfibio poi di e così via fino a
arrivare all'uomo
si è visto che questo non è poi così
corretto però secondo me l'ontogenesi
della conoscenza
e cioè lo sviluppo della conoscenza in
un singolo individuo che parte da zero
fino ad arrivare un'istruzione completa
deve ricapitolare la filogenesi della
conoscenza e cioè come abbiamo
conseguito la conoscenza che oggi
possediamo come specie
e qui torniamo la genesi cioè torniamo
agli animali e alle piante
i bambini hanno voglia di imparare
queste cose la scuola dovrebbe
cominciare con questo dovrebbe
cominciare insegnando ai bambini a
guardare il mondo e guardarsi attorno
poi le astrazioni vengono dopo se
cominci con le astrazioni
e non c'è concretezza
non ci sono buoni risultati
e come imparare a parlare quando noi
impariamo a parlare
impariamo con la concretezza cioè
sentiamo gli altri che parlano parliamo
anche noi
se
poi dopo impariamo la grammatica la
sintassi cioè tutte le cose formali che
regolano il nostro parlare ma parliamo
anche prima di averle imparate se ci
avessero insegnato a parlare
costringendoci a imparare la grammatica
e la sintassi
prima di parlare non parleremmo così
bene
il risultato di questi istruzione è che
in questo campione per esempio nessuno
sa come funziona il suo corpo
non è una cosa buona no poi ci insegnano
magari conosci te stesso ma se non sai
nemmeno come funziona tuo corpo
io ho partecipato ha tantissime
trasmissioni
televisive
sulla natura il livello di conoscenza
che trasmettono è
limitatissimo gli animali più importanti
del pianeta sono i copepodi
c'è qualcuno che sa cosa sono
nessuno
il pianeta è coperto per il 70 per cento
dall oceano
però l'oceano non è una superficie è un
volume
più del 90 per cento dello spazio
abitabile della vita e oceano se sul
pianeta non ci fosse l'oceano la vita
non sarebbe possibile se il pianeta
fosse coperto completamente dall'oceano
la vita andrebbe avanti tranquillamente
i copepodi sono dei piccoli crostacei
che mangiano le piante più importanti
del mondo che sono le diatomee
dinoflagellati
che sono degli organismi unicellulari
tutti i pesci quando sono larghe
mangiano copepodi e quindi reggono i
copepodi reggono le catene alimentari
del 90 per cento dello spazio abitabile
dalla vita
sono gli animali più importanti del
mondo
orbo se le avete mai viste in una
trasmissione televisiva
tutte le trasmissioni sulla natura
tendono a far dire
a chi le guarda
e quindi ci sono sempre animali
carismatici
bisognerebbe
dopo questo o di ammirazione
arrivare anche a di consapevolezza
e quando mi dicono
vabbè dillo allora era in diretta la
trasmissione
dillo che ti copepodi sono gli animali
più importanti del mondo io dico che i
copepodi sono gli animali più importanti
del mondo e dietro di me e mettono un
rowe tifero che è come se io avessi
detto i cavalli e avessero messo una
cavalletta
la cosa grave che nessuno se n'è accorto
che c'era un rowe tifero invece che un
copepodi cioè il nostro livello di
ignoranza
sulla natura sia su noi stessi la pipì
sia sulla natura nel suo complesso i
copepodi
è praticamente totale
per cui noi abbiamo una cultura che ha
abolito la natura non c'è
e questo ha portato la necessità di
transitare da un sistema in cui la
natura non ha nessuna importanza e ora
ne stiamo pagando le conseguenze a un
sistema in cui la natura è centrale
perché senza la natura noi non possiamo
vivere
però questo non si può ottenere se non
c'è una cultura dietro e la fabbrica
della cultura la scuola e la scuola non
dà nessun tipo di cultura per quanto
riguarda la natura
tutt'al più quando io vado nelle scuole
dove mi invitano a volte su la7 il
giorno della terra alla settimana di
questo di quello che parlano di natura
fanno fare le poesie ai bambini e quindi
fanno la poesia sulla natura e siamo di
nuovo ai fu siccome immobile e quindi
c'è qualcosa che non funziona
in più una cosa che
deve essere fatta e che non viene fatta
è insegnare le connessioni l'ecologia e
la scienza delle interazioni
le materie dividono la conoscenza con
compartimenti stagni e non permettono
l'elaborazione dei rapporti che ci sono
tra le varie discipline
e anche questo è completamente sbagliata
per cui secondo me la scuola dovrebbe
essere
rivista completamente e dovrebbe
cominciare imparando quello che dice la
genesi dare il nome agli animali dare il
nome gli animali dare il nome alle
piante puoi imparare come funzionano i
sistemi
che formano cioè gli ecosistemi imparare
come funziona il nostro corpo
poi possiamo cominciare a contarli e
imparare anche le tabelline a imparare
anche delle poesie perché è giusto che
sia anche questo ma se manca questa base
che è la natura senza la quale noi non
possiamo vivere
ovviamente costruiamo una conoscenza che
autoreferenziale e che non ha nessun
rapporto col mondo vero che è lì fuori
un mondo che stiamo rovinando
applauso vuol dire che mi posso anche
fermare ma in effetti manca mancano
pochi secondi e quindi mi posso fermare
anche qua e quindi il titolo di questo è
abbasso la scuola con la k
[Applauso]